le cinéma le metteur en scène claude
miller reprend pratiquement la même
équipe que celle de l'effrontée pour
tourner la petite voleuse ce qui nous
permet de retrouver charlotte gainsbourg
et simon labrosse interprétant le
dernier scénario écrit par le regretté
françois truffaut jean chatel oui c'est
ça eh ben vous sortez d'un bulgare
légèrement sur la droite
cette aimable autochtones des environs
d'orly nous a renseignés sur le lieu de
tournage du nouveau film de claude
miller la petite voleuse dans l'action
se déroule dans les années 50
il y retrouve celle qui nous avait
révélé dans l'effrontée charlotte
gainsbourg
aujourd'hui c'est une scène de course
trouve que le petit ami de
charlotte dans le film qui la grosse à
un rêve de devenir champion de motocross
il fait de la compétition
pour charlotte gainsbourg la petite
voleuse c'est vous et c'est une
délinquante juvénile avant la lettre
et vous êtes conduite à voler pour
gagner un petit peu d'argent pour le
plaisir dit désolé parce que j'ai pas ce
que je vais voir si je venais de soute
femme je parle des cigares être
gainsbourg va rencontrer un autre jeune
voleur c'est simon de la brosse je
pénètre dans un bureau où il ya des
enveloppes pleines d'argent pour les
secrétaires et puis là elle me
rencontrer le me dénoncer elle part avec
moi dans la rue et de la part une
aventure fantastique de deux jeunes gens
pleins de vie pleine révolte et ils
partent tous les deux comme ça et sur
leur side car et c ils ont envie de
vivre quoi ils ont envie de ces mais ils
ont envie de tout ce que les jeunes ont
envie aujourd'hui et si on vous disait
que vous deviez maintenant tourné dans
des superproductions et d'avoir presque
toute la responsabilité du film sur vos
épaules ça ne vous fait pas peur
je veux pas la voir avec sa timidité et
sa réserve se révèle étonnante présence
de celle qui sera bientôt pour nous la
petite voleuse charlotte gainsbourg